Briefly in the dark yet again,
Shumani Namatozi,
Isaac Mudao,
Wise Man Baloi
Fonzo Lizebbe
and Chanyo Munyai seemed visibly karma.
The five have been in custody for over a year now.
The stand accused of conspiring to break into Moses
Malolakis home,
shooting him to death
and shooting and injuring his son.
They have pleaded not guilty to all the charges. Today,
the accused legal representatives applied yet again
for them to be moved from the Polokwane Correctional
Facility to the Thando Correctional Centre.
My clients instructed me to bring it to your attention
that they are forced to pay
what they refer as the Protection fee.
They are forced to pay for meat.
They are forced to pay even for bed renter.
And as a result, my lady, they are,
yes, they are paying my debt.
My lady, the arrangement in prison
together with the officials and some of the prisoners
is that an, an account number be given to my clients.
They finish that account number to their family members.
Man is paid from outside, my lady,
by the family members of the accused.
That is the unfortunate
situation my clients find themselves in, my lady.
Judge Simina said she will refer the application
for the transfer to the judge. President
Simina has rescheduled the matter for two weeks
from April the second to the twelfth.
Malolaka's family has experienced
disappointment with the postponement.
This postponement have been there forever
since from 2022 are getting postponements
and We are no longer sure about what is happening here.
You must remember
there were six things
which have been said by the witness, er,
that there is names which has been in there.
That is Bafana and the driver.
And then even today,
we don't see them being arrested.
We know that there are,
there are masterminds in this.
We only don't know how these cults are waking
because it's like, eh,
I'm say, I'm so sorry that I can't use the name,
but it's like
if the case is compromised, I won't,
I won't lie.
As a family,
a spokesperson
and as a brother to my brother,
I don't see justice prevailing to,
to his murder.
They accused,
face several charges,
including one of murder and another of attempted murder.
Randhaniralipasha,
a s a B C News, Balukwani.